so the last video I hopefully proved to
you at least you know maybe it doesn't
make intuitive sense just yet but I
showed you you know that the probability
of a and B is equal to the probability
of a given B times positive B and the
probability of B given a is equal to the
probability of B given a time's a and
then we play it around a little bit we
got this and this is called Bayes
theorem or Bayes law and I will now show
you how you can apply this formula but
it shouldn't be informal you should
always be able to intuitively come to
this conclusion even if you forget Bayes
theorem which I do all the time and then
I go through that thought process that
we did at the end of the last video over
again but let's see how we can apply
this to this problem so we want to
figure out the probability that we pick
the two-sided coin given that we observe
that when we flip it five times we got
five heads so let's say that this is a
this is event a and this is event B all
right so we can use Bayes theorem so the
probability that I got two sided Dyer at
the two-sided coin given 5 out of 5
heads is equal to the probability and
I'm actually going to think about what
this fraction means in a second but it
means the probability that I got a given
B so it's this the probability that I
got 5 out of 5 heads given the two-sided
coin times the probability of the
two-sided coin right B we defined event
B as a two-sided coin times the
probability of two-sided coin divided by
the probability of in general the
probability of getting 5 out of 5 heads
the probability of 5 out of 5 heads all
right well what's the probability of
getting 5 out of 5 heads given the
two-sided coin
well we already rewrote that down we're
guaranteed to get 5 out of 5 heads so
that's 1 and what's the probability of
getting the two-sided coin
well that was 1/10 right and what's the
probability of getting 5 out of 5 heads
in general well we figured that out
I think either in the last video or the
video before that right it was I forgot
the exact number and I'm actually
it was something like it was 1/10 plus 9
over 320 and write it so this was 3 this
is 32 it was 41 over 320 we figured that
out in the previous problem right so
this is over 41 over 320 and so what do
we get we get this is equal to 1 over 10
over 40 1 over 320 now what is that
equal to that equals to 1 over 10 times
3 2000 over 41 let's divide the top of
the bottom by 10 so it equals 32 over 41
that's interesting I actually find that
really interesting I don't know which
coin I picked out of the bag but I know
that if I flip that coin five times and
all five of our heads that there's a 32
out of 40 one chance this is maybe a
little bit better than a 75% chance that
I picked the two the the two-headed coin
we could say and let's let's let's think
about this visually a little bit so you
know if this is the entire universe of
what could happen and we said you know
1/10 of that this is the - this is the
two-sided coin this is the fair coin and
then out of all of that the situation in
which we get five out of five well those
could be well pretty much all of the if
we got the two-sided coin all of that is
going to be five out of five and then
some small fraction 1/32 of the fair
coin so this yellow circle represents
getting 30 getting five heads in a row
so if I want to know what's the
probability of the two-sided coin all
Bayes theorem is saying is well okay
we observed that we got the two-sided
coin oh sorry we observed that we got 5
out of 5 heads right so we now know that
we're in this yellow universe because
the yellow universe represents the area
or all of the outcomes where we got 5
out of 5 heads and then we say well out
of those outcomes what percentage of
them involved me getting the two-sided
coin well if we look here all of these
sorry I'm edit
if we look at it here this is the area
out of the yellow where I had the
two-sided coin and I got the five out of
five and so this is going to be roughly
32 out of 41 of the yellow of the CLO
area so that's a visual representation
of Bayes theorem this says the
probability giving two-sided coin given
I got five out of five that says well
okay
let's look at the universe of you got
five out of five and then what
percentage of that universe involved you
getting essentially the two-sided coin
and that's that and that's all base
theorem essentially tells us so let's
let's see if we can apply that let's do
it a more interesting one let's say
actually I'm going to leave it there and
then I'm in the next video I will I will
apply Bayes theorem to more interesting
problems see you soon